[Music]
hi everybody
i'm pleased today to be talking with
jocko willick who i've talked with
on his podcast on three separate
occasions
i don't think i've had jocko on mine
and my memory isn't what it should be so
but i'm i'm quite sure
that we've so far when we've talked it's
been on your podcast so i thought
i'd take the time today to get to know
you in some more detail jocko is an
american author podcaster
and retired naval officer who served in
the navy seals
he co-authored the books extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
with fellow retired seal leaf babin
would i pronounce that right it's
actually leif babin
oh so i didn't pronounce it right at all
leif babin he hosts a weekly podcast
with brazilian jiu jitsu practitioner
echo
charles called the jocko podcast he has
a million subscribers on youtube
and his podcast attracts many more
listeners he co-founded the management
consulting firm
echelon front llc and has extended his
business development on a number of
additional fronts
his military service included combat
actions in the war in iraq where he
eventually commanded the sealed team's
three
task unit bruiser that fought in the
battle against the iraqi insurgents in
ramadi
and was honored with a silver star and
bronze star
for his service he achieved the rank of
lieutenant
commander good to see you again jaco
it's good to be here i'm yeah i feel the
same way
that it's good to be here um i'm really
looking forward to our conversation
so i'm glad i'm glad that you were able
to
gut through that ridiculously long bio
and
i felt that as you got to the end of it
you were breaking
free of the chains of that reading so
i'm glad it's over with yeah well it's
so much better just to talk than to read
in
in this sort of format but at least
everybody
who doesn't know already has some sense
of of who you are some
minimal sense of who you are so tell me
what's been happening online with you
over the last couple of years because we
haven't spoken i would say it's got to
be two years i think
something like that and so i
i've i've cast an eye on what's been
happening
with you on youtube and some of my staff
have filled me in but i'm really
curious tell me about what's happening
with your youtube channel and your
online activities your podcast and all
of that
um yeah a few years ago i started a
podcast i i
that was actually was quite a few years
ago now it was in 2015
it might have been kind of as the as the
explosion of
prior to the explosion of podcasts in
fact i think i read something that said
at that time it was like 17 of americans
were listening to podcasts and that
number's
much much higher now and i kind of got
lucky
because at the time uh
tim ferriss was had one of the most
popular still very popular but at the
time
just because the numbers of podcasts
that existed
his podcast was even more popular and
and i went on his podcast and
when he got when we got done recording
and he pressed stop on the
on the record button he looked at me and
said you should have your own podcast
and i kind of took that you know and and
noted it
and then uh a little while later i was
on joe rogan's podcast and
he had you know obviously another one of
the most popular podcasts in the world
and he told me in the middle of that
podcast that i should have my own
podcast
and so when guys like tim ferriss and
joe rogan are telling you to have your
own podcast
you have your own podcast now i came to
realize later that
joe rogan actually would tell everybody
to have a podcast so
maybe here he would tell everyone oh you
should start a podcast well i actually
listened to him
and and so i started that podcast and i
would say i
probably if if if somebody would have
asked
you know what should a person do to make
a good podcast or
or or maybe not a good podcast but a
popular podcast somebody would probably
say
um make it probably a half an hour to an
hour bring a bunch of different guests
on so that you can hear a bunch of deep
a bunch of different people talking and
you know talk about
positive things in the world and so
instead of doing any of that what i did
was i have a podcast that's between
two and five hours long oftentimes it's
just me
talking reading from a book and
reviewing a book
and usually the books are about war or
suffering or some kind of human atrocity
and so
that's what my podcast is and really
what it boils down to is it's
it's an it's learning about human nature
and for me human nature is best revealed
or most clearly revealed
in times of suffering and one of the
i guess a pretty good monopoly on the
market for suffering is
is war and right in there and as well as
you know human atrocities so i started
that podcast and
and like i said when i started it there
weren't that many there weren't as many
as podcasts as there are now
so it got some traction out of the gate
and it kind of just stayed there so
i was very lucky in that respect and
i've been doing it ever since i've
i've put out one podcast a week for five
years i've only missed
one one week in there
and and that was when um my
my best friend was killed in a parachute
accident and so i didn't put out a
podcast that week
but other than that i've been very
consistent
and then the youtube channel is well
it's
it's kind of the podcast and then we do
some excerpts there
and little clips and stuff like that and
and echo charles
uh i forget what you called him in the
bio a brazilian jiu jitsu practitioner
he's also a a video guy and so
he makes his little he makes little um
clips and puts special effects in them
and stuff because
he's creative and bored which means
it's a great combination for someone
that you're that you're working with
it is indeed so i think that's what's
been
happening online for me and for the past
few years
who who do you who's your audience do
you think
or do you know yeah i know actually
quite well that my
my demographic is people
it's people it's human beings really
it's it's all over the place
and when i go and do live events i'll
have
just the entire spectrum of humans there
hey look is there a
is there a you know kind of a typical
person yeah there's a typical person but
we get everybody on the spectrum from
the grandma to the the little kids you
know i've written a bunch of kids books
and the little kids show up as well
great pretty pretty body
kids books yeah pretty broad demographic
that's i meet all kinds of people
everybody from a
i'll meet a firefighter and then a hedge
fund guy and then
a stay-at-home mom and then a retired
marine
it just meet everybody it's and that's
the audience
do you do you have any sense of what it
is that's attracting people to your
podcast i mean
you you you sort of approach that
tongue-in-cheek in some sense for
for a dark topic you know you
concentrate on things that are
that are pretty negative or they're
pretty dark and so
as you said that might fly in the face
of any advice you'd get about what to
talk about but obviously i mean one of
the things i've encountered is that
there's a very there's a vast hunger for
serious
dialogue and i i mean one of the things
that struck me always about your podcast
was
you often read something that's very
very
uh emotionally demanding
stark harsh rough and
well and it's interesting to think about
why people might
be attracted to that what's your sense
and also why are you doing it
i think that it's emotional
i think that these are emotional topics
i think these are things that people
can be a little bit afraid of and a
little bit nervous about
and being able to brush up against them
a little bit gives them a little bit
more
familiarity with them and therefore when
you see when you come close to things
that are that stark and dark and
horrible
it also makes you look up around at the
present situation that you're in and
maybe it doesn't look as awful
um yeah so so there you touched on two
things about
knowing something about history that
might be really useful or about human
affairs
right one is that i mean it's a tenet of
of of clinical psychotherapy that
a voluntary approach to what's
frightening threatening
even disgusting is curative it has to be
voluntary
and it it can't be too intense right
because if it gets too intense it can
actually hurt you but
if it's voluntary and measured that
actually seems to strengthen people it
develops resilience
and i would say that's one thing that
virtually all well-trained clinicians
agree on
is that that kind of exposure whether
it's discussing
old difficult experiences in an
autobiographical manner or whether it's
actually going out into the world and
facing things that you're afraid of if
you're an elevator phobic for example
you might be faced with
confront confronted with the necessity
of at least looking at an elevator which
is something you might avoid if you're
phobic
and then so that's the first thing so
there is some
pronounced human tendency to be
attracted to what's dark because
that is a pathway to mental and physical
resilience and then the second thing is
which i also think is extremely
important is
it's useful to cultivate gratitude in my
estimation
and one of the ways that you can do that
because
you you take a lot of what's good in
your life for granted it gets invisible
especially if it's predictable it gets
invisible and that's unfortunate because
it's still
rare and precious
and if you know how terrible things can
be have been or could become
then that can alert you to how fortunate
you are when
all hell isn't breaking loose right now
everywhere in your life
so yeah and you can also
sort of learn some skill sets of how to
handle these tough situations when you
get in them
and if you can see that someone went
through something that's much worse and
what did they do to deal with it how did
they get through it
what did they think about what did they
do you can say okay well i've seen that
before
and the situation i'm in isn't quite as
bad but
i know that that person took action i
know that person's stood up and
and made a move and made things happen
and tried to move forward
and maybe that's what i should do too so
you can you can definitely garner
some skills from the past
and right so that's a third element is
that it can expand your notion of
human competence and that's
you know i think that's partly that's
one of the reasons that people love
watching
um high-end sports performances
you know because you think well look
there's
that's what a human being is capable of
isn't that so
remarkable and i am one of those and so
that's a limit case but
there's obvious obviously room for me to
develop and that's all that's something
that's very hopeful
and so if you are in dire straits and
you've seen that other people can get
through that you think well maybe
maybe i could get through that if i
could just learn how to do it
so i i had a guy on my podcast who had
written a book his name was william
reader
and he had he was a helicopter pilot in
vietnam and
he was shot down well he shot down two
times the first time he was shot down he
was able to make it back to friendly
lines the second time he was shot down
he was captured and he was captured in
south vietnam which is
actually worse you you didn't want to
get captured in south vietnam because
then they had to get you to north
vietnam to the prison
and getting to north vietnam while
you're patrolling through the jungle for
months on end is not a good thing and
at one point he's in a two foot tall
bamboo cage
in the jungle and he's
his legs are shackled and it's night
time
and he's trying to sleep but he's having
trouble sleeping
because the rats are gnawing at the
wounds
on his legs
and so knowing that someone could
suffer through that and survive
and get through and and make it out the
other side
and then carry on with a completely
productive life
tells me that we are pretty resilient
as a species if we can dig deep and find
that resiliency
yes well that's exactly the kind of
story that
also makes you much appreciative of the
fact that you have a bed in an
air-conditioned room
that in a in a house in a town that's
not
burning to the ground with rioters and
you have that every night and so you
take it for granted but
but it's still worth noting that it's a
kind of miracle compared to all the
alternatives that might manifest
themselves
yeah i think people appreciate that i
think people you know look
how many movies are have been made about
war countless movies have been made
about war
countless books have been written about
war so human beings are definitely have
some sort of a
i don't know if it's a fascination or or
at least
an appreciation for the sacrifice
and the effort that goes into fighting a
war and and
i will tell you and i i can't speak for
everybody
but certainly me and the kids i
many of the kids i grew up with and then
many of the people that i served with
that's what we wanted to do we had some
kind
i had some kind of an interest it's such
a great thing for you to be able to say
you know because there's there
i remember watching this kid once i saw
him in montreal and he was standing he's
a big kid about 6'5 i would think and
he was wearing these punk boots that
were like military
knock-offs essentially and um
he was standing there he's about 17 or
18 and he's standing there on the corner
of this outdoor shopping mall
carrying these two pink shopping bags
and looking completely out of place and
i thought
you know if you went there and offered
that kid a chance to go off and have an
adventure you know to have a battle he'd
drop those shopping bags and be gone in
two seconds because
he wants something more than to be he's
not built for that it was so incongruous
you know
he wasn't built for that and william
james the american philosopher said that
we needed a moral equivalent to war
because war calls people to
extremes right to to to to the extremes
in their life
and there's something about that that
was obviously compelling as you as you
say
it's uncomfortable as well to to to
state that blatantly because
obviously peace is a desirable condition
but the question is then
well how do you put sufficient adventure
into the piece
and that's a very very that's a very
complicated problem
uh yeah you know it's um
it's it's it's very true in the fact
that
in war i was lucky enough to go
and i was lucky enough to serve in in
combat and to be in a position of
leadership in combat
and in those situations i was
able to witness with my own eyes
on the one hand the most heinous
and despicable acts that human beings
can partake in
and i was also able to witness with my
own two eyes
these soldiers marines the guys that
were in my task unit making the most
incredible sacrifices
for their friends so yes
there is an extreme to war and like you
said
it's not something you wish on anybody
and i had this conversation with sam
harris a while ago
because he called me out and said you
know you're talking about how hard war
is and it's terrible but at the same
time you say it's the best thing
that you have been through and i i asked
him if he'd ever
known anyone that had cancer and
survived it
and oftentimes those people will say
it's the best thing that happened to me
i wouldn't wish it on anybody
but i'm glad it happened to me and
that's kind of how i feel about war too
i i wouldn't wish
war on anybody but i am i wouldn't
i wouldn't trade it for anything
so when you look when you look back
on your involvement in the war
in in iraq and your country's
involvement
what what do you make how do you make
sense out of it
morally i mean we're in that domain
right now you know you you tell
tell me already that you're pulled
between these extreme views you don't
wish war on anyone i'm i mean if you
have do you have a son
yes how old is he 18.
i well so so then
you think i presume but i
or perhaps i wouldn't i wouldn't deign
to presume
if you could have what you wanted for
him
would that be peace
of course okay okay well that right
okay so of course of course
of course but well
right right exactly well the other thing
the other thing that you do as far as
please correct me if i get any of this
wrong but i mean part of what you're
also offering to people
is the is the the call of a kind of
radical discipline right now you post on
instagram
your the times you wake up in the
morning
correct it's yes 4 30
something like that and pretty regularly
and
i guess you do that to show people that
you can get the hell out of bed at 4 30
and get your day going and
yeah maybe not i would love to tell you
that i was that
um had that much for
forethought into when i started doing
that but i was on tim ferriss's podcast
and he told me i should join twitter
and i kind of said what's that and he
showed it to me a little bit
and he said you really should join this
it's a way you can communicate with
people and i said okay
fair enough so i signed up for twitter
and then
whatever the next day i woke up in the
morning and didn't know
what to write or what to do so i just
took a picture of my watch and you know
here i go
and other people kind of noticed that
and so that's kind of how
that whole thing started but
yeah well it's not it's not always the
case that when you do something new and
creative you know why you do it and
sometimes you have
and even if you think you know why you
do it you might find out five years
later that there were 10 other reasons
that you did it that you weren't aware
of at the time like
we live beyond ourselves all the time
that's especially true if you're
entrepreneurial and creative because
you're changing who you are all the time
and there's no reason to assume
that your understanding of yourself
would keep up with the changes
so my take on my take on the instagram
posts was
well what i just what i just mentioned
it's like well
you know yeah you can sleep until 10
o'clock in the morning if you want but
you can also get a jump on the day and
i think part of what makes your i think
part of what makes what you're doing
attractive
is that there's so little emphasis in
our popular culture
especially especially with regards to
the
so-called mainstream media on discipline
and responsibility that there's a
tremendous hunger for anything that
pertains to that
and you have a right to be discussing
that i would say because of your
because of your background which if
nothing else required a tremendous
amount of discipline
yeah and i i ended up writing a book
called discipline equals freedom
and i'm lucky that i wrote it when i did
because
if i would have written it two years
later everyone would have said oh
everyone's talking about discipline now
so yeah discipline absolutely discipline
does bring you freedom in life and
that's something that i
kind of figured out over time i didn't
well so what do you mean by that like
how did you figure that out and what do
you mean by that because they're often
and and you know the the classic sort of
uh
what would you call it romantic rebel is
someone who
has is free from excessive order let's
say
they don't see they see freedom and um
discipline as antithetical rather than
seeing one as a precondition for the
other and
so so how did you learn that discipline
was a precondition
for freedom if i've if i've got the
equation how did that manifest itself in
your own life
so we'll start off by saying this and
look i was a young kid i joined the navy
to go in the seal teams i went through
seal training i showed up at a seal team
seal team won and when i got there and
as i look
back this is a very
powerful thing even though it's very
simple when i was so i'm
19 years old when i show up at seal team
one i'm done with the basic seal
training
and i have a goal
in my head which is that
which is this i want to be a good seal
that's what i want to do that's like i
don't know about anything else
i this is what i want to do i want to be
a good seal that's what i want
i want to be a good seal
and so as a 19 year old with all kinds
of energy and
we haven't talked about my childhood yet
but i was kind of like a very rebellious
kid when you talked about seeing a kid
that looked like
you could have handed him a a a a a club
or a battle axe and he would have
probably been feeling a little bit
better
i was like that i was constantly looking
around for a club or a battle axe
because that's what i felt like i needed
to do and it was beautiful because i was
running around the
running around the woods as a young kid
playing army
and i just went and actually played army
you know that's what i ended up doing
so i never really had to do do you know
force myself into some mold that i
didn't want to be into
so i got to seal team one and now i
i just want to be a good seal that's
what i want and so now
that starts steering some of my
decisions
and and for the most part it steered my
decisions in it
in a decent direction now there were
some times where
as i look back now what i thought was a
good seal
was a little bit off but luckily it
wasn't 180 degrees off it might have
been
30 degrees or 40 right right and as i
got older and more mature and i figured
out
more about what that ideal should look
like to me and i could keep chasing that
idea that was good
but even even to be a 19 year old kid
with a with a 70 or 80 degree
corridor to move forward in is not a bad
thing
no it's a gift it's a gift exactly
so then i'm looking around
at other seals that were older than me
and more senior to me
and trying to figure out which one of
those guys is a good seal
yeah and what i realized was that the
guys that were working harder
for the most part were good seals now
they were look there's just some people
that are just
way talented right we'd show up you know
three minutes before a run or three
minutes before we do a shooting
competition
and they could just walk through it no
problem right and
that's great for them it wasn't me i i
wasn't i'm not that great at anything
but i saw other guys that might not be
great at anything either but they
worked hard they showed up to work early
they did the drills that they were
supposed to do
they had discipline and when you have
has amalgamated statistics i hope i get
this right but it's approximately
correct
if you work 10 longer hours
you make 40 percent more money
right and so and and i think your
comments about talent are also dead on
it's like
in any field of enterprise there are
people who are phenomenally gifted
and and then if they work really hard
they're even more phenomenally gifted
right those are the people who
break records but
that talent apart hard work
actually works and with virtually
everything
it might not make you the best at
whatever it is you're pursuing but it
will certainly make you better than you
are and
and then i have in this i have this new
book i hope you got a copy
because we did you get a copy okay so
i'm bringing it up for a particular
reason i have a chapter in this book
called uh
well there's two that are relevant
imagine who you could be and then aim
single-mindedly at that that's one and
then the
the course or what would you call a
complementary chapter is uh
work as hard as you possibly can on
one thing and see what happens and
that's also predicated on this idea that
discipline is a precondition to freedom
so so you were fortunate like you had
this goal right so that meant you had a
goal which is a really big deal
because you could learn about goals you
had a sense of
uh what a higher mode of moral being
that
i would rather be a good seal than the
person i am now well it's a it's a code
of behavior and a way of perceiving so
there's an ethic in that and then you
said as well you know your conception of
what
good seal meant changed as you matured
but that's also fine it wouldn't have
changed unless you would have pursued
that initial
um only partially accurate goal and so
that's also a really good thing for
people to understand is like
if you don't know what you're doing aim
at something
is it the right thing no but it's better
than just
shooting randomly so you aim at
something and then as you aim and you
move towards it
you're going to find out why you're
wrong and then you might
recalibrate your aim and that's going to
happen over and over because as you move
towards a goal it recedes
or it broadens or it recedes and
broadens and otherwise you'd run out of
things to do
so but anyways back to the back to the
story you're
you you have this this this identity and
you said it was
it was there in you all right from the
beginning because you would play army
in in the by yourself even in the in the
in the forest by your house i presume
and how how old were you do you think
when
how long back can you remember having
that as a fascination
i do not remember wanting to do anything
else
so would you say what is is that as
early as four
three five preschool something like that
can you remember playing when you were
that young
i i i can't remember
um you know a specific age but if i
think back to
hey that looks like what i want to do
i remember i want to be a soldier
and do you okay you remember when you
were a kid i mean i'm fascinated by this
because
well one of the things i really noted
when i had kids was how much their
personality was there right from the
beginning
like my children are quite different
they have their similarities but they're
quite different from one another and
those differences were there right from
the beginning and they've maintained
themselves throughout their lives
um and so that it's fascinating to see
that that
destiny in some sense is built right
into the person to begin with
and so while this was built into you by
all appearances
and so it manifested it in itself in
what attracted you
even in play as a as a child and that's
the beginning of identity formulation
that
that play and so what was it about being
a soldier
that you think attracted you when you
were a kid like what
what was it that was so compelling
because being a soldier is a
multi-dimensional
identity there's there's there's the the
the physical combat element of it
there's the strategic element of it
there's the
the discipline the camaraderie what
what were you playing do you think
i got asked this i was talking to some
folks at the special operations command
the other day and they asked me they set
me up with this kind of
beautiful possibility
or opportunity for me to give some kind
of an incredibly beautiful
answer to this very question you know
and
there was something along the lines of
you know at what point did the did the
opportunity to serve and sacrifice for
your country
reveal itself to you or something along
that those lines
and all i'm thinking about is when i'm
8 years old 12 years old 15 years old
i want a machine gun and i want to go
fight a war that's what i want to do
i would love to tell you i would love to
tell you that i you know
read some heroic book i i read
the odyssey and and realized that i
don't read any of that stuff
well that wouldn't be anything to do
with it anyways right i mean that's why
i'm curious about what it was so early
you know and so okay so for you it had
something to do with weaponry
apparently i got to tell you a story
about my father okay and
tell me if this act ec like produces any
echoes
before you go yep weaponry was like
for sure that's fine but it could be a
club
it wasn't it wasn't like i wasn't a kid
that was obsessed with guns
okay it was and and maybe it was just
we're gonna get out and
and run around with sticks and try and
hit each other
or get into rock fights do you ever have
rock fights
well we we had ice fights because it was
northern alberta but also dirt lump
fights and now and then those would have
rocks and
i can remember um it was usually the
protestant kids against the catholic
kids i mean there wasn't that much of a
division between those two in our town
but the catholic kids had their
high their junior high in high school
and we had ours and so
our gangs were separate and so
we would have dirt lump fights in the
vacant lots where buildings were being
constructed and those were extremely
exciting
you know now and then you'd take a dirt
lump rock in the mouth and that was a
little bit on the painful side and
but but but there's no doubt that it was
extremely exciting
and so and you know i cut you off about
your dad and the gun oh well
my dad told me something and then this
might be more relevant to
to to guns but my dad collects
single-shot rifles
and he has a lot of them like hundreds
of them and he's a gunsmith and
and makes stocks and hand carves them
and
anyways he's he's an artisan in that
regard and
it's really it's a it's a real focal
obsession he's a
great shot he shot at the provincial
level which would be the state level in
the u.s
um but it was single shots and and
he hunted and so we grew up on moose
meat and elk meat and
and he brought elk into northern alberta
as part of a
repopulation attempt anyways um
i thought for i could never understand
his fascination with with
guns because it was really a deep
fascination so it was
it was uh something that elicited my
curiosity and at one point i realized
that
he only hunted with single shots so he
had one shot at
whatever he was hunting so it had to be
a good shot and so he was pushing
himself
and then i realized well he was really
obsessed with hitting the target
taking aim and hitting the target
and i it was about that time i learned
that the greek word for
for sin hamartia meant to miss the
target
so there's this tight alignment between
taking careful aim at the center of
something
precisely and then bringing yourself
into alignment so that you would
hit that target there's a deep morality
in that it's a morality of hunting it
might be a morality of combat
and it's really deeply embedded inside
of people and that was what had
my father in its in its grip
and so i would i i was wondering if the
if if you're if you're uh
the automatic interest that that even
the club
elicited in you had something to do with
that that seeking that hunting that
that target seeking or if you know
perhaps i'm
barking up the wrong tree i would say
i know but when you when you were
talking about getting hit in the head
with a dirt
clump and whether you get hit or not
when you get done with that situation
you are in an elevated state of mind
because
that was dangerous and it was
a very high level competition because
even when you're
throwing a baseball or or
you know kicking a soccer ball around
there's no real
danger in that situation but when
someone's hucking
dirt clumps at your head you get
a legitimate rush from that
and it feels good and it feels
it's exhilarating one of the most fun
yes there's no doubt that it's
exhilarating one of the most fun days i
ever had as a child
this was less dangerous i i lived next
door to a policeman
an rcmp officer and
we went out one day i was probably about
eight into my
neighbor's backyard and she had
green tomatoes everywhere far more than
she was ever going to eat
and we had a green tomato wore for like
an hour and a half
and he was moving them at a pretty good
velocity so if they caught you
especially in the head
you know you kind of remembered it but
it was exhilarating
and it was really fun to engage in that
with him and i really do
remember that and i do remember those i
hadn't until today but i do remember
those dirt lump wars and
there is an exhilaration in pushing
yourself like that
so and i also don't i don't want to give
the impression that i was
you know running around with camouflage
paint going to high school or i was
you know i i was doing a bunch of other
stuff too i played soccer i played
basketball
i i we had you know a bunch of different
bands we played music i
i played bass in a band i sang in a band
i played guitar
we we did all kinds of other stuff but
yeah i was always kind of just in the
back of my mind
sort of wanted to do that job
all right so you went to the seals
and tell us about that a bit
it was awesome
you know it's you're uh you're making
more money than you could ever figure
out to do
with you know i'm 19 years old and i am
the richest
person that's ever existed in my mind
because i'm making
whatever it is however many thousand
dollars every two weeks
and you know my expenses were nothing
and so you're just
totally stoked you're getting you got a
great job you're working out
you're shooting machine guns you're
blowing things up you're hanging out
with a bunch of
bunch of other guys that like to blow
things up and
you you you can fight each other at the
drop of a hat
and then you get done with a fight and
you shake hands and then and then you go
eat a steak
and so you're just in this environment
and it's
perfect it's it's freaking awesome
so what was it like it was awesome
that's what it was like
it's funny you read accounts of the navy
seals and i've never
read it as enthusiastic an account as
that account right there
and so then how long after you what
happened after you were done your navy
naval seal training what direction did
your military career take
yeah so i got done with seal training i
went to seal team one it was 1991. i
just missed the first gulf war
i was all brokenhearted about that
because this war had happened and i
didn't know when another one was going
to happen
and so what
what do you do is you train and and we
trained a bunch i did
a bunch of seal platoons which is you
form up with a group of guys you
do a a training cycle together as a
platoon and then you go on deployment
overseas
and when there's no war going on you go
to other countries and you work with
foreign nationals and
you train them on the skill sets that we
have and
learn some stuff from them and then you
come back and you do it again
and then eventually from there i i went
into uh
where i became a trainer at seal team
one um
and taught the tactics to the the seal
platoons that were now
training to go on deployment and i did
that for a couple years and then i got
picked up for a commissioning program
and became an officer in the seal teams
which moved me up into a leadership
position
and then i did a couple deployments as
a young seal leader then i had to go to
college the navy sent me to college
because
in order to be an officer in the in the
navy you have to go to college and i
hadn't been to college
where did you go i went to the
university of san diego
you went to the university of san diego
what did you take there i
i was an english major
all right so you finished college and
then what happened you're not going to
ask me why i was an english major
why were you an english major i thought
when he hears english major he's going
to say wait a second
here you are this guy talking about
machine guns and blowing things up
what in god's name are you going to go
study english for i have to say that
that thought did pass through my mind
okay uh why was i an english major
i was an english major because believe
it or not when you're in the seal teams
and especially when you're
in any officer position you have to
write and read
all the time so when
one of your troops does something and
they deserve some kind of recognition
for that you have to write them
an award and if the award is written
well there's a much better chance that
it'll actually
that be given to the person that you're
writing it for you have to write
evaluations
for your troops and the evaluations that
you write
is how your troops are judged so that
they can be promoted
on top of that if you want to go do a
mission
you have to write a concept of
operations which is a
document which is five six seven eight
pages long
that you send up the chain of command
that then they scour through and
see if they're gonna prove your mission
or not you know that's so insanely
important you know i mean
one of the things i did a talk at
harvard
four years ago and
i pointed out two things to the students
in the audience
one was that
a tremendous amount of civilization and
effort had gone into producing the
institution
that they were now part of and that
everyone
who was part of that institution was
hoping that they would come there
and learn everything they possibly could
that was relevant and important and that
they would be the best
possible people they could be and they
would go out in the world and
do as much good as they possibly could
that was the
essential mission of the enterprise and
that was really the case and also
that learning to write in particular
was going to make them more powerful
than they could imagine
and a number of students came up to me
afterwards and said
i really wish someone would have said
that to us when we first
came here and it's the writing part of
that i i kind of got obsessed with that
when i was working as a professor and
i'm working on a piece of software right
now
to help which will launch soon to help
people write
because what i observed in my own career
and it's so interest the parallelism is
so interesting but not
surprising is that nothing can stop you
if you can write
and it's for the reasons you just laid
out it's like
when you write you make a case for
something whatever it happens to be
and if you make the best case well then
you win
and you get whatever it is that you're
aiming at
and so you know you said maybe that's
why i didn't ask you why you went into
english i
i guess that might have been the reason
is that the utility of learning to write
is so self-evident to me that it could
pass by without question
but it's also interesting to think about
how it fits into
this this broader well let's say
at least partially military strategic
way of looking at things
you know you you describe the intense
relationship between
marshalling your arguments properly
getting everything in
order on the page and making strategic
progress
truly in the military sense that those
things are tied together
very very precisely and it's obviously
your ability to communicate as well
that's
that's well look what it's done you have
your podcast you have your youtube
channel you have your books which many
of which you self-published
so that ability to communicate is it's
i just can't understand why it's not
presented especially
not entirely but especially to
adventurous
well let's say young men we could say
young people you're adventurous
you want to make a mark is you bloody
well better learn how to write
because if you learn how to write well
then you can think and you can
communicate your thoughts so not only
are you deadly strategically
you become extremely convincing and then
you can go and do anything you want and
no one will stop you
and that's never told to people and i
i i don't really understand why you know
you hear the pen is mightier than the
sword
which is just a cliche unless it's
fleshed out but
the reason you laid out the reasons
perfectly
yeah you have to communicate what
happened as well as having it had had it
happen
right so you you already connected the
dots but
obviously not only am i having to write
and present
my argument i'm also having orders being
issued to me which are written i'm sure
you've heard the term rules of
engagement
well rules of engagement is a 12-page
document
that is in a bunch of legalese
and i've got to translate that document
to my
troops some of whom you know barely
graduated high school
and so i've got to be able to do that so
i've got to be able to read and then
write and be able to then communicate
and and talk to the team and brief them
in a manner that they can actually
understand what it is i'm talking about
and what it is our mission is and
why we're doing this mission so that was
why i decided to study english
when i when i went to college and
believed so that was a conscious
decision
absolutely and with that end in mind
that it was
so tell me exactly what the decision was
with regards to studying english what
did you know that because
it's not as you pointed out it's not
self-evidently the most
practical of pursuits and not
necessarily what you'd expect someone
with a military orientation to pursue
right here's the here's the thought
process
i want to be a good seal the good
seals that i see can communicate they
can write
and they can read that's what i need to
learn how to do
i need to learn how to do that better so
that i can
persuade my chain of command that we
need to do this mission or we need this
piece of gear
or this guy over here needs to get an
award or he needs to get promoted
all those things are done by being able
to write and communicate properly okay
so so let's say you take the example of
a seal who's
got it all but this
literacy okay so what
what happens to him compared to someone
who has
all those skills well if he
can't if he can't write well and he's
in charge of six guys and one of those
guys
works hard or does something that
deserves to be recognized
this is the responsibility of that
leader to write that person an award
okay so he can't reward his he can't
reward his his good
workers his good soldiers he can give
him a pat on the back but the battle
back isn't going to get him promoted
an award is actually worth some points
towards your promotion
and the people that are on that board
that are giving that reward
they're never going to meet that leader
and they're definitely not going to meet
that guy there's no
there's no bias it's based on this piece
of paper that you hand in you're handing
this piece of paper they read the piece
of paper and they say
award approved or award not approved or
you want to do a mission
and you send that up the chain of
command and it's the same thing
it gets to a certain point where they're
just looking at it and reading
and trying to decipher this pile of junk
that you put together
and by the way if i'm in charge and
jordan sends me
a concept of operations that doesn't
make any sense
why would i possibly let you go out and
execute an operation
that i can't even understand what it is
you're trying to do
so it has a huge impact it has a huge
impact
okay well i'm dwelling on this because
it's it's upsetting to me i would say
that
young people in particular aren't
stringently instructed that
the ability to that literacy makes them
powerful
in every way they can possibly imagine
except the absolutely immediate
and so it's just sad to me that it's not
sold in that manner you want to be weak
stay illiterate you want to be strong
it's like put yourself together
physically fair enough man get brave
and street smart but then you could add
some literacy to that and you're an
unstoppable machine
so i concur 100 and
you know you said being literate makes
you powerful and
throughout recent history if we're
trying to oppress someone what we don't
want them to be able to do
is read or write or or articulate
themselves
right well we haven't even talked about
reading you know we just talked about
writing and fair enough so but
obviously you studied english so you
also read and so what's the advantage to
that
as far as you're concerned practically
speaking
well um obviously there are
so many lessons that you can pull out of
books and you
you can get to a point where nothing
really surprises you because you've at
least seen some
indication of what can unfold through
reading
so again for me it's very much focused
on
combat and war but
there's there's lessons that you learn
and you say oh i i've seen that before
there there's a book it's it is a book
called about face which
i think the last time you and i talked
you were i think you were writing the
forward
for for the gulag and
i was about to write the forward to i
don't know if that's your favorite book
but
i i was lucky enough to be able to write
the forward for my favorite book which
was re-released because i was talking
about it all the time
and the book is called the book is
called about face
and it's it's about a guy that was in
the korean war in the news in the
vietnam war
and his name is colonel david hackworth
but
i would read that book when i was on
deployment i would read
open up that book anywhere and i would
read two pages or three pages before i'd
go to bed if i
was in my bed that night and and there
were so many
lessons that correlated to what i was
actually going through and a real
obvious example was when he was in
vietnam
he's working with the south vietnamese
soldiers and
therefore by proxy the south vietnamese
government and guess what
they're all corrupt and they're not
motivated and they don't have the right
gear and here we are in iraq and we're
working with iraqi soldiers and
therefore by proxy we're working with
the iraqi government
guess what they're all corrupted they're
they're they're not well equipped
and how do you how did he deal with it
how do we deal with it
so there's an example of when you read
you can learn
and you don't have to you don't have to
go through the school of hard knocks you
don't have to get
punched in the face repeatedly with
things that turn out to be
situations that other people have
absolutely gone through
and the amount of the amount of the
the the the level of capability
increases so much by seeing something
one single time well if i see something
one time
i i'm i'm infinitely better than if i'd
never seen it before so if
if it's like those
those little puzzles they give you a
little puzzle some kind of a mind bender
right the nine benders only work on you
one time the riddle only works on you
one time then you i know the answer to
that
that's the answer you never get fooled
by that again so
just knowing just seeing it one time
you're infinitely better so when you
read enough
you're capturing all these lessons and
and you know what it's
i gotta say this
it's not just reading it's not
just reading and and i learned this
because
as i started doing my podcast and many
of my podcasts are just me
reading books i realized
how to read more intently even more
intently than i did when i was going to
college and i was going to be
you know writing a paper about a book
and so i'd read it in a certain way
but you even that reading was a little
bit detached
a little bit detached because you're
looking for a theme or you're looking
for character development
or what have you but when you read to
learn about human nature and life
you you you detach less and you kind of
put yourself in there and you experience
it a little bit closer
and then when you take a step back you
go oh yeah i i know what he was thinking
right there because i was right there
with them
and so there's a certain attitude
you kind of have to put yourself into
the work
and and really read it with that kind of
uh intensity for lack of a better word
is it is it possible for a human being
to read
intensely because that's what i try and
do i get it
that's no different than than acting
intensely or playing intensely
of course you want to put the book on
you want to become that person
that can rattle you up man especially if
the person is thinking all sorts of
things that you've never thought
i mean i love reading for that reason i
could pick my peers too which i really
loved it's like
well you know i have these people around
me but then there's these people
who who've lived before me and in
different places and i can set them up
on my shelf i can enter into their
world and i can benefit from everything
they've thought and saturate myself with
that person
it's and it's very disruptive especially
if the person that you're reading has a
mind that's more powerful and more well
developed than your own
i mean friedrich nietzsche spun me
around for about three years and
i was reading young at the same time
intensely and
the same thing you know it was very
disruptive
but unbelievably useful unbelievably
useful to try on other people like that
and you get the benefit of their entire
life distilled into their
into their book you know it it's 30
years of work i read this one book
called the neuropsychology of anxiety
which is a it's a great scientific work
i think it's the greatest
neuropsychological work of the last
50 years it's very hard book i think it
has
1800 references something like that and
this guy jeffrey gray
he actually read all those references
and he understood them
and so it took me six months to read the
book
but i got an entire education out of it
i got to
experience in six months what it took
him 30 years to learn
like what a gift that is it's it's it's
unbelievable
i was i was listening to an interview
with uh gary
kasparov i think you said russian he was
a chess
world champion for 20 years something
like this
and he they asked him anyway
the interviewer didn't ask him directly
if he could beat this young young guy
named magnus carlson who's the current
kind of prodigy of chess
he's just phenomenal in the highest
chest rating ever et cetera et cetera
and he didn't get asked directly if he
could beat him
but it was definitely implied if i
remember the interview correctly and
and what was very interesting to me gary
kasparov
there was two things that i found
interesting number one was he said
i he's younger than me and he didn't
mean that and
like that was an advantage for for gary
he meant it he's younger than me so he
has an advantage
as an advantage because he's younger and
i kind of thought to myself well that's
kind of weird
because this isn't a physical this isn't
a wrestling match this isn't a jiu jitsu
match
why would that help and then sure enough
you
learn a little bit about cognitive
decline and
gary kasparov is 57 years old when he
did this interview
and guess what you start well depending
on who you are but you start to see
cognitive cognitive decline around that
time and i'm still it kicks in at 25.
there's you can iq is pretty unitary but
you can fracture it into
crystallized and and fluid and fluid iq
is what enables you to learn and it
declines from 25 onward crystallized
intelligence continues to grow
roughly speaking because it's partly
dependent on such things as vocabulary
which you can learn and which accumulate
but interestingly enough you know you
were talking about physically
the best way to stave off cognitive
decline
is not cognitive activity it's exercise
weight lifting and cardiovascular
exercise can will
is the it's by far the most potent means
of staving off cognitive decline
so kasparov would have the advantage in
terms of experience but
the younger guy would have the edge on
sheer raw brain power
that's what i thought too that's what i
thought too
but guess what it's wrong and it's wrong
for the exact
reason that you just said so
magnus carlsen when he's 11 years old
he gets to open up a book and see every
single
match and move that gary kasparov right
that's what they do they document that
stuff
and so what he got to do was what you
got to do you got to learn a person's 30
years experience in six months
well this young kid ma so so this where
it might have taken gary kasparov
you know eight years or four years to
figure out how to get out of some
particular
quandary on the chessboard well magnus
just opened to a page in a book and said
oh that if i ever get in that quandary
i'm there
and so what magnus got to do is he got
to start from here
right and build and so i make this point
from a leadership perspective
yeah we can do the same things as as
leaders we don't have to figure all this
stuff out
we can jump up to gary kasparov's level
or at least get a baseline of what he
knew
and and win because we learned
it's very interesting to me well you
think and again with regards to selling
this sort of thing
um you know i'm stunned that it's
possible to make history
boring for example people should be so
enthralled with history that they can't
get enough of it but
with reading imagine you have this
opportunity to learn whatever you want
from the greatest people who ever lived
along that dimension
and and
well it's stunning to me that that is a
hard
sell it's mysterious that that
it's that that it isn't something that
everyone is just
clamoring for i mean that to me that
points to a devastating failure
inadequacy of the education system a
mysterious inadequacy
yeah there's a i think maybe the
transaction isn't always
clear for people i i always talk about
well if you're gonna sell somebody
if you're gonna sell somebody a book you
know if i'm gonna sell you a book
jordan you've gotta give me 20
and eight hours of your time right
that's what you know you're going to
give me you're going to give me 20
and you're going to give me eight hours
of time which you would probably
you know have other things that you
might need to do and the transaction is
not always clear
of what you're going to get out of that
especially when look you can spend a lot
of time reading books and
not get as much as you might want you
might not get your twenty dollars worth
out of a book
so you have to be somewhat selective now
luckily it's not even that hard to
figure out which books to read because
there's so many reviews and
and and history about where these books
came from and the
and the productivity that they resulted
in so but i think it's hard sometimes
for
look i can i can only speak for myself
when i was
younger it was really hard for me to
figure out that transaction
yeah fair enough like i had a librarian
who um when i was
13 who
told me what to read which is what a
teacher should do right
there's nothing a teacher can do for you
that's better than say well here's 10
books that will change you completely
and who actually knows that to be the
case
one of the things i'd really like to do
i i've toyed with
um well with the whole concept of online
education
one thing i'd really like to do is to
divide up the
variety of of domains of learning and
identify
the top 10 books in each domain so to
ask an expert it's like well you're a
historian you're a great historian
what 10 books are crucial and i have a
list on my website a list of recommended
books there's about 100 of them that
have been instrumental for me and
lots of people have used that list to
purchase books
so that's been really good but i'd
really like to extend
extend and expand it yeah i have the
same thing on my website
the books from the podcast and same
thing
all kinds of those books get sold and
it's it's beautiful to see but
the people that are checking the website
or listening to the podcast
they know that that those books have
been through a filter they're there for
a reason they're there because they're
going to be worth that transaction
and i think that's a a tough sell for
for
a lot of people they can't figure out
maybe they've invested in books before
and they didn't quite get the return on
investment that they wanted and buy
two or three books and 50 or 60 dollars
and
20 or 30 hours yeah that's that's a
great observation i think because
one of the advantages to coming from a
literate background
is that you do in fact reduce the
transaction costs
because there's an infinite number of
books i mean well no there isn't but
as far as we're concerned there might as
well be and so the question of what to
read really is daunting if you don't
know anyone who reads
where do i start and and and how can i
not be a fool in doing this
so well okay back to english so what
what were you reading when you were in
university was it was it fiction
novels was it non-fiction what what were
you what were you focusing on
uh it was like your basic
english literature that's what i studied
and so i
read everything i read everything you
know from each one of the little periods
and it took the various classes and
and really uh as trite as this may sound
it was actually the the most impact was
from shakespeare
it was the most impact on
on multiple levels and i'll tell you the
primary level and when i've covered
shakespeare on my podcast i
explain this to people people think well
you know i didn't really understand i
i read it i didn't understand it and i i
said so i start off when i talk about
shakespeare on my podcast i
start off by saying listen
if you think you're gonna just pick up
shakespeare open it up
and read it and understand it you're not
going to
because it's barely written in english
it's barely written in english it's
almost another language
and so you're not going to be able to
just pick it up and read through it
it's it's it's written in in almost
other language
so what you have to do is you have to
start to interpret it and so what i
realized
with with shakespeare is number one the
weight of the words
that these words were so pregnant with
meaning
that you had to pull those words and
parse those words and pull those words
apart to see
all the depth that each individual word
had and then the way that they're
put together and what was great about
this was
by the time i was back because then i
went right back into the seal teams and
somebody would hand me a rules of
engagement document
that was written by some lawyer in
washington dc and i'd pull it out and
say wait a second this word i don't know
what this word means
let's pull this word out let's see what
this let's see what this actual
definition of this particular word is
and how that changes
my viewpoint of these rules of
engagement and how can i translate that
for my troops so that they actually know
what to do
so that part uh for me was
from a reading perspective starting to
read shakespeare
and and saying oh okay you're not gonna
understand this and if you don't
understand something
that's okay you pull out the oxford
english dictionary
and you look it up and then you not just
find out what the meaning of the word is
but what's the root word and where does
it come from and what kind of depth
and what kind of and that's really
that's that's unbelievably useful too
to discover the connotation of words and
the oxford english dictionary is
particularly good for that because
you you discover things that you'd never
guess by looking at how the word
developed
i mentioned the word hamartia like the
fact that the word for sin was derived
from an archery concept was revelatory
to me it's like that's so cool
it ties this moral concept
abstract philosophy back down to
something as as
primordial as weaponry and hunting
and just the fact that that's the
metaphor is absolutely fascinating
and and then there's the overlap in
meaning that i already referred to and
virtually every word is like that
because word is an ancient artifact it's
like
it's it's it's like an it's like an
animal in some sense it has an
evolutionary history and it transforms
across time
and each word kind of it carries the
echoes of its past with it too because
each word um attracts other words
in a particular unique way so it kind of
lives in a word ecosystem as well
and the ecosystem contain information
about the history of that word and
you think well why is that important
it's like well hey
guess what you think in words you talk
in words
you have all these archaic uh
what are what these archaic entities
these words these living entities that
you use it's like the more you know
about them the more you know about you
the more you know about other people and
the better you are at
formulating and communicating your ideas
there's nothing left
there's nothing lost in that kind of
investigation nothing
there's nothing but gain there so yeah
and that's
that was so that was the uh that was the
english road for me and
and it was good thing i asked you that
question eh yeah
it was really really insightful for you
to come up with that thank you
thank you all right so so
and you did you had did you enjoy
university
did you find a community there no okay
so when i was going to university i was
married
i i had two kids when i got to
university i had three kids when i left
i was not a university student i was
in fact in fact i would sit in the front
row
during my classes i would have three
pencils
and three pens lined up and staged on my
desk
i would be ready to take notes when the
when if the teacher said something i
didn't understand i'd be sitting in the
front row raise my hand i don't
understand what you just said can you
explain that and i mean you know i'm 28
years old
and there's a bunch of 18 years olds in
there and they just want to you know go
out and hang out with their friends
and i'm there i'm in there to
i'd love to really sound come off
sounding good and tell you that i was
there to learn but i was there to get
a's which meant i did have to learn
so i i went at it as a competition
and i was competing not with the other
students i was competing with the
teachers
because i'm a little bit crazy sometimes
i would want to make sure that they
couldn't ask me a question on their test
that i didn't know the answer to so
that's what i did and so did i have fun
maybe not and one thing when i got back
to the seal teams what i told
the guys i'd say you know what i learned
in college and they'd say what and i
said
i learned never ever ever ever get out
of the teams
ever never get out of sorry get out of
never get out of the teams
the seal teams never get out of the gate
okay
okay well you know i taught um older
students
in boston and undergraduates and
the the undergraduates especially in
boston but also at the university of
toronto were very very bright
and generally very hard working the
older students were generally not as
highly selected but man they were
committed
and most of them had had jobs that they
weren't thrilled with let's say
and had a hunger for what education
could bring them that the younger people
lacked and so it does seem to me often
and maybe this is just because i'm
getting older that
after high school it might be good for
people who want to pursue university
to go do something that they're
qualified for
which isn't much at that point for a
year or two
so that when they do go to college or
university they understand
just exactly what they're being offered
yeah but i i couldn't agree more
working in the regular world will
definitely
make you appreciate the opportunities
that you may have if you
go and learn more in the world
all right so you you came out of
university you had three kids
you were married what happens next uh go
back to the seal teams
and be go through the rest of my career
uh
dude showed up at a seal team september
11th it happened
so i show up at a sealed team i i become
a platoon commander at a seal team
and then go on deployment i get done
with that deployment
that deployment was primarily to baghdad
although we worked kind of all over iraq
got done with that deployment i went and
became the aid decamp
for the admiral that was in charge of
all the seals
at that point in time and so that was uh
sort of an
er well not even sort of it was a very
administrative job
but it was also a huge opportunity for
me to get to see
the seal community in the most broad way
that i could
so i got to learn a lot there and then i
went back to
a seal team and was now what's called
the task unit commander which is
two sealed platoons combined together
and i was in charge of two seal platoons
combined together which is called the
task unit
my task unit was called task unit
bruiser and
we deployed to ramadi iraq and that was
in
the summer of 2006 very tough fighting
a very tough battle and came home from
that deployment hey so can i let me let
me ask you there so
can you tell me can you describe
a typical day or a typical week like
what was it like to be there
i like all the details what you get tell
me what happens when you get up in the
morning
what did your day look like so
we're there we showed up there and
as soon as we got there and we knew
going into it
in 2005 2006 if you can remember
watching the news in 2005 2006
just about every day you would see in
the news that
there was three
soldiers killed in a lombard province or
five marines killed in al-anbar province
or three marines wounded in al-anbar
province
and the capital of alambar province is
the city of ramadi and the vast majority
of those casualties were happening
inside the city of ramadi and and we
knew that going there
and when you say we you say we were
deployed there who are you
you're obviously referring to the
country to your country but
what does we mean when you make when you
say that when i say we in this
particular case i'm talking about
my seal task unit so i had and that's
how many
how many people yeah so i had about
35 to 40 seals most of the time
and then another 60
around 60 support personnel and these
people
are armorers that
you know can fix our weapons and and
mechanics that can fix our humvees and
intelligence people that gather
information for us and radio operators
that can receive our radio calls
so there's a big support network that
goes
with the the sealed task unit as we
deployed and why was it a seal
enterprise
what was specific about this deployment
that that required this
the whatever it is that the seals bring
and what is it exactly that the seals
bring that's specific
so on this particular deployment at this
time at this point in time
seals were deploying to iraq
all the time where there was always
seals in iraq my first deployment was in
2003 2004
and we were in the beginning of that
deployment we were the only sealed
platoon there
and then by this time there would be
many more seals i forget what the number
is but
so we were in iraq and we were
conducting
special operations missions and
in particular in ramadi when we got
there so
standard seal operation on my first
deployment
was get gather intelligence
from various sources so so through
various sources
we would gather intelligence about the
location of
a bad guy okay so you had you had a
variety of people who were targets
identified and they were leaders of of
what made what marked them out as bad
what were their characteristics these
are these are people
well we want to talk about their
psychological characters no no no i mean
you might not be able to do a better job
than that
i can tell you what they were doing for
a living was trying to kill americans
trying to kill coalition forces trying
to kill other iraqis trying to
create chaos and mayhem for the interim
government in iraq
these are were they generally leaders of
leaders of a group that you would target
or the
are these people who were involved in
the army on the other side or
like put them in context yeah so there's
no
there's no i mean the iraqi army is
actually on our side right
so these the iraqi army is our friends
and that's who we're working alongside
and now early in the war
not so much because the the coalition
forces
made a decision to disband the entire
iraqi military
right well this is why i wondered if
there were people with on the military
to what degree there were people with
military chaining that were facing you
yes so since that happened a lot and as
a matter of fact in
in the city of ramadi there used to be a
massive
military iraqi military base there and
so a bunch of former iraqi military
lived there
there was a whole area that was called
the it was there was an area called the
officer housing there was an area in
ramadi that was called the officer
housing where iraqi officers used to
live so
and i'm not nailing that name but it's
something like that um
so yes there was there was former iraqi
regime army people that were out there
fighting
there's also foreign fighters and so
would they have their own little groups
there are bands of people that were
fighting with them you were talking you
were targeting leaders
i'm just wondering how people were
selected so the seals were after
specific individuals generally speaking
yes and here's what we figured out
if you only target the leaders well it's
going to be
a lot harder to catch them because
they're
laying low and they're moving around and
and
they try and they try and give
misinformation about where they are and
what not
so well we'd go and go out and grab you
know one of their lieutenants
grab one of their soldiers and find out
where the lieutenant is grab lieutenant
find out where the leader is
so there would be these cell networks
these little these little networks and
maybe they're a mortar cell and they're
they're dropping mortars they're a
roadside bomb cell and that's what
they're doing
and so we would figure out who these bad
guys were and then through these various
intelligence sources
we would find out a location maybe it
was a mid-level guy maybe it was a
high-level guy maybe as a low-level guy
and then once we know their location
we're going to get them what were the
typical motivations of the people
that you were pursuing what were they
fighting for
so there's a variety of motivations some
of the
you know if you're a front line guess
what if you're a 15 year old kid with no
money
guess what's a good motivator money and
you
and the insurgency
yep the insurgents say hey we'll give
you 100 bucks to go launch an rpg at the
american base
that so that's their motivation end of
story uh
the higher you get up the chain of
command the the more
you're going to start leaning towards
legitimate
jihadists that now there's jihadists
throughout the chain of command don't
get me wrong
and and i mean hardcore jihadists and
and i remember the first time i
i was in my first deployment the first
time i saw
a legit hardcore jihadist
you you can tell that these this guy
hated us and it was very clear from the
look on his face when we captured him
it was completely he he was filled with
seething hatred so there's jihadists
throughout the chain of command and that
guy was like
so so the the jihadist motivation was
well by definition in some sense a
religious motivation but your experience
of it was that it was primarily a
visceral hate
and hatred for what do you think i mean
obviously you're an occupying force
let's say
and you know and and america is seen
at at least among the jihadists of that
time as
as a a truly satanic force
i suppose i mean what's motivating what
was your experience of what was
motivating the hatred
yeah it's it's everything you just said
but i mean you can trace it all the way
back to
the israeli-palestinian conflict i mean
you can
they're they're gonna draw and see view
view
the west as evil as the great satan
and and so that's what what did you
think at that point
about the morality of the endeavor i
mean
because this is why i'm curious like and
please do correct me i'm sure i'm wrong
about
many of the things that i think but it
seems to me that
the clearer your moral sense when you're
engaged in a battle
the more likely you are all things
considered to win
because you're not part of you isn't
going to be fighting against you
right and i mean in any enterprise it's
like that if i find that if i'm involved
in a pro
project and i have reservations
then the part of me that has
reservations 20 of me
pushes against the other 80 and then i'm
only 60
as effective as i might be and so
whenever i engage in an enterprise i try
to walk through it ethically
and see well am i actually committed to
this
what qualms do i have what what doubts
do i have
what resistances do i have because
that's going to make me weak
and so when you go into battle i presume
it's the same thing that you have to
believe
i know they say that soldiers also fight
very hard
for the guy who's in the foxhole next to
them so there's that brotherhood
camaraderie
but you go there as a representative of
your country as well your nation and
and there is that there has to be that
ethical dimension to it and so
what how did you guys deal with that
looking at what we're doing and and
what's what's
really interesting is even though when
you stare at it from a strategic
perspective when you say oh as a western
power
as this country we're going in here
and we could argue all day long about
whether
that's a right call or a wrong call
whether that's morally correct or
whether it's an immoral move we could
have arguments about that all day
yes well they've been going on for 3000
years in the middle east right
right endless arguments about what's
right and and
here's what here's what
one of the nice benefits of
being on the ground is you get to see
what's happening what's actually
happening so
what you see in iraq when you're
actually on the ground
is for instance in ramadi what you see
and what we saw
is the iraqi populace
who are a bunch of normal people that
want to
carry out their lives and raise their
kids and
run whatever business they're going to
run that's what they want to do
they want to they want
they actually want life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness is what they want
that's a normal iraqi family when we
would
when we would go to an iraqi family's
house that's pretty much what you're
dealing with
and amongst those normal people
that just want to live their lives in
peace
there are insurgents and
the insurgents want power they want
control
and they are willing to do anything to
get it
and so when you see
fathers beheaded and their heads
left in the yard of a family
because he had you know
had really he he was he was working with
a shake
that had said things against al qaeda
and now this guy is beheaded uh we there
was a guy that was skinned alive
there was torture there was rape
so when you are on the ground and you
see this stuff happening
and you see the local populace
clapping and cheering when you kill
insurgents
your strategic vision
isn't quite in focus as much as what
you're seeing right in front of you
with your own two eyes and so therefore
the
20 of you that might be arguing uh
whether this is right or wrong when you
see
families slaughtered you you
very quickly um tell that 20 of your
brain
that you you don't you need to look at
what's happening right here
this is this this is this is immoral and
we need to do what we can
to help these people and do you
did you feel then and and then again
now i mean it's a quagmire
it's an ethical quagmire the middle east
and so
it seems in some sense that no matter
what you do there
it's wrong and
i'm not trying to convince you of that
believe me i'm i'm really
curious about this you felt when you
were there that you were on the side
that was doing the right things do you
um and now when you look back
i mean i don't know what to make of what
what happened with the us in the middle
east over the last 15 years
i'm just as happy and perhaps you are as
well
there's less engagement in foreign wars
now than there was 10 years ago in the
u.s
right that seems to have receded to some
degree and that
perhaps that's a good thing
what do you think about the in about
about
america's involvement in iraq what
conclusions have you come to
so you you talked about this
argument that you're going to have in
your own head
well you are also going to have
that argument on a national level right
you're going to have a national
level argument of whether this is the
right thing or the wrong thing to do
so my
scale my measure of this is
if you are going to go to war
if you are going to go to war you have
to make sure
before you go
that you have the proper will
the proper will and there's two types of
will that you need
to have if you're going to go to war the
first type of will that you
need to have if you're going to go to
war is you have to have the will
to kill you have to have the will to
kill
and guess what i am sorry to inform
everybody
it is not just the will to kill the
enemy
because when you go to war war is an
imperfect is an imperfect
endeavor and no matter how hard you try
to just kill the
the enemy you will kill civilians you
will kill women
you will kill children that is what is
going to happen
that is what is going to happen if you
go to war
so you have to make sure you have the
will
to do that that sometimes you're going
to drop a bomb
and it's going to land and it's going to
kill women and children
that's what's going to happen and
anybody that thinks anything different
is naive and ignorant
we seem to let our politicians often
convince us that that's possible but
it's not
so you have to have the will to kill and
then on top of that
obviously you have to have the will to
die
you have to have you have to know and
understand
that if you embark in a war
your sons and daughters are going to
be killed that is what is going to
happen and anybody that says
it's not going to happen is naive and
ignorant
now i think before we go to war
oftentimes we rationalize
that we can mitigate the risk of killing
we can
mitigate the risk of dying and for some
reason we think we can mitigate those
risks down to zero which is impossible
so
if you have the will if you look at a
situation
and say we need to do something here
for moral reasons for national security
reasons
we need to take action okay so let's
so let me ask you a question there if
you don't mind
um you know whenever i
have had to take difficult action in the
past
so take to take a risk
my justification for that so what
allowed me to organize my will let's say
was
a belief that inaction was a worse crime
so
i'm trying to think through
what it takes to conjure up the will
that you just described
morally speaking and it's very difficult
to talk about the morality of war but
it's absolutely necessary
clearly do you believe that
in the situation in iraq do you think
that the argument was laid
forth it's it's it's such a sh it's
it's
so there was a terrible attack on new
york
911 and the response was
focused on iraq that's correct so far
yes on afghanistan immediately and yes
thereafter focused on iraq yes
all right it was never obvious to me why
the focus shifted to iraq
do you do you have any sense of why that
was i know that there was a lot of
thought at the highest levels of the
american government
prior to 9 11 about iraq
and so there was a plan that was already
in some sense in place
for iraq but it isn't obvious to me why
attention was shifted towards iraq
in the aftermath apart from the fact
that that plan already existed
uh i think the shift
came from i'm trying to think of
some kind of a metaphor here but you
know you've got
you've got some rats in you know in the
garage
and the rats have nod through some of
the wiring
and so you go and you
you you know you try and kill the rats
in the garage and you realize
you know what this isn't the only place
that these rats seem
could could be there could also be some
rats over here in the basement
and we have wires over there too
we better go handle that situation as
well
you said that you were overwhelmed by
the reality of the situation on the
ground
my first deployment to iraq we we worked
with we we just worked with seals
basically all the operations we did was
just with seals when we went back to
iraq in ramadi
we were ordered to work with iraqi
soldiers
now the iraqi soldiers were poorly
trained they were poorly equipped
they had low motivation some of them
were not very trustworthy
and we were going out into the worst
battlefield on planet earth
at the time and it was
it was pretty hard to make sense of that
order right
but when i thought through the order you
know why
why is why is why is my senior
leadership ordering me to do this
well the answer is quite clear after i
thought about it a little bit
hey the reason that we have to do this
is because
we need to work with the iraqi soldiers
so that the iraqi soldiers become
proficient enough
that they can handle the security in
their own country of course
yes okay so my
my senior leadership isn't telling me to
do something because they want me to die
or want my troops to get wounded and
killed they're telling me to do
something because
it's a strategic move where in hopefully
two or three years
the iraqi military will be at a level
where they can handle security in their
own country
okay got it okay that's part one
well when when we got ordered to
work with iraqi soldiers it wasn't just
it wasn't just
my seal task and it was everyone all
coalition forces all american
army and marine corps was getting told
you'll work with iraqi forces and
everyone kind of had that nervous
feeling
right hold on a second you want me to
have this person that has a rusty ak-47
and a pair of sandals you want that
person to
to to support me out on the battlefield
that doesn't make any sense and so what
the american forces did
was when they were ordered to take iraqi
soldiers with them on an operation
then they would go out with a platoon of
40 americans
and they would take two iraqis with them
because they were told to take iraqis
plural so that means two
that's what we're going to do and they'd
leave them in the humvee and they go
conduct their operations
well senior leadership got wind of this
and this obviously is not in the spirit
of
of what we're being told to do you're
not going to get
a nation's army trained up by taking two
soldiers out
so the next thing the leadership said
was
okay here's the new order for every
one american that you bring out you have
to have
seven iraqi soldiers with you so yeah
so they imposed a ratio on us now
ramadi at this time was a complete war
zone other parts of iraq
were actually somewhat pacified and in
many of those pacified areas
that order actually made sense the the
the iraqis in some areas the iraqi
soldiers in some areas were actually
capable
of conducting decent operations with
very little american oversight
and the level of violence in those areas
wasn't that bad
so it was okay well in ramadi it didn't
make any sense whatsoever
so i'm being ordered to take one seal
for every seven iraqi soldiers well
first of all because of the fighting was
so bad in ramadi
many of the iraqi units only had
10 or 15 or 20 people
in their platoon so if i was going to
send out
seals i would only be able to send out
two seals
15 iraqi soldiers so now which two seals
am i going to send
am i going to send the medic
well i want to send a medic for sure but
guess what i also need to send a machine
gunner in case we get into a firefight
what about the radio man that actually
calls for help what about the point man
that actually knows where we're going
what about the leader who's going to
make decisions out there
what about the explosive ordnance
disposal guy that can dismantle bombs
from going off
so who am i supposed to leave behind
it doesn't make any sense the the danger
to the troops
is so much higher in that situation
so what did i do did i say hey that's
what i'm being ordered to do no
i took all this into consideration and i
and i you'll appreciate this
i wrote a point paper up my chain of
command
explain the situation of what was
happening explain the number of
casualties explain the level of violence
explain the size of the iraqi
elements that we were working with and
said can i please get a waiver
for this and allow me to take however
many seals i've deemed necessary to take
to be safe
and my chain of command read it and said
yeah sure jock will do whatever you want
to do
thank you so that's okay so
what you what you what you're telling me
is that you take what you're told to do
and you take what you know to be the
case on the ground
and you try to do you try to take both
of them into account as much as possible
well you're also shunting information
back up the hierarchy hopefully to
modify their
decisions the decisions they're making
that aren't in accordance with the
reality on the ground
right right so you do i mean you do your
best under the circumstances but that
that makes that
that that seems to be that's that seems
to be a good answer
but but it escalates obviously it can
escalate higher than that
right it can the decisions the orders
that we're being given
can escalate to a point where maybe this
entire thing that we're doing
i think is wrong right right okay so now
we get into a situation where
and the reason that i i have to explain
all these other things is because
it happens very rarely it happens very
rarely
that you know someone in the military is
looking at a decision that's being made
on a big scale and says i think this is
totally and completely wrong now i will
tell you
and i wrote about this in my last
leadership book leadership strategy and
tactics
if you're being told to some to do
something that you
believe is completely wrong well
i would love to tell you that that's a
black and white decision but guess what
it's not
even that's not a black and white
decision because jordan if you order me
to go and assault a machine gun nest
that's
that's on a hill with my squad and i
know
that this is a machine gun nest in a
bunkered position in an elevated
position
with interlocking fields of fire and if
we go up that hill
we're all going to die and i look at you
and
say hey hey boss i don't think that's a
good call they're elevated they're
bunkered
they're interlocking this doesn't make
any sense and you go no jocko shut up
and do it i said
i'm telling you jordan this isn't a good
idea and you say no shut up and do it
now here's my decision point if i say
you know what i will not do it
i will not do it you know what you do
you go cool jocko you're fired and you
get your yes man come over
and your yes man comes and you say go
assault that machine gun nest and he
takes the squad up and he gets everybody
killed
so i surrendered my influence
when i when i drew that line in the sand
and said no
and you doomed other people to death and
i doomed other people to death
now my boss orders me you order me and i
say okay boss got it
you you definitely want me to do this
there's no way out yes you definitely
got to do it okay
all right guys here's what's happening
we're going to start we're going to get
into a covered position we're going to
start maneuvering towards this thing
we're going to see what kind of fire we
receive if we start
receiving overwhelming fire i'm going to
lock some of you guys in that position
and i'm going to send another squad over
to the flank
and we're going to we're going to take
out this machine gun from that's from
another angle or
i'm going to hunker down in that
position and we're going to call for air
support
so you're decomposing you're actually
decomposing the process then into micro
elements and then testing the micro
elements
then you can report back with that
information yes
right right very smart very good we have
to be very careful so
when you talk about oh i don't think we
should go into
iraq i don't think we should go okay so
what am i gonna do hey i don't think we
should go
now are there times where that might be
the right decision
there are some times like that where
maybe i think that
me as a senior leader standing up and
saying no
to my boss is gonna make you know jordan
suddenly looks at me goes wait a second
jaco's always been a good guy
and now he's sitting here telling me no
he's really serious about maybe i
maybe i'm not seeing something maybe i
can get you to rethink your position
that's a risky move though it's always a
risky move to kind of draw a line the
sander
kind of an ultimatum because when you
use up your capital
you burn your leadership capital it's
even worse than that you just
completely surrender your leadership you
don't even use it you you
you obliterate it it's gone you have no
more influence you're done
so we have to think very long and hard
about those things
and so when it comes if if i was
i was never put in a position like where
i didn't where
where i thought that what we were doing
as a country was wrong i'll tell you
actually probably the closest i've come
to that
was i think it was 1993 the
the massacre was unfolding in rwanda
there was the the um the
uh hutus were killing the tutsis by the
hundreds of thousands
and i was on a navy ship
um off the coast of off the coast of
africa
on standby to go into rwanda as this
slaughter took prey took place
and we didn't do anything
we didn't do anything so that's the cost
of not going to war there
austin not going to war and there's a
very you know it's a very interesting
i'm sure you've heard of the the the
massacre that took took place in me lion
vietnam
and and one of the most interesting
things in that reprehensible scenario
is what stopped it
what's so this is this this this horror
is unfolding there's
there's murder mutilation rape
just going berserk a company of american
soldiers
is murdering raping mutilating bodies
just absolutely heinous absolutely
reprehensible
and while this is happening a helicopter
pilot
comes in and sees what's going on
and these guys have lost their mind
really the guys on the ground have lost
their mind the helicopter
pilot flies back to base he walks into
the tactical operation center and says
hey they are killing civilians out there
the commanding officer gets on the phone
and says
hey stop killing people and they stopped
immediately
they stopped immediately that's that's
what tells you how important leadership
is leadership is the most important
thing on the battlefield and if you have
a leader that's going to let things
start to go in this direction all it
takes is one person to step up and say
hey everyone stop what you're doing this
is wrong
so you get a situation like rwanda
we didn't really do anything we we
didn't do anything
and what would it have taken if if we
rolled in there
and said hey no more don't stop do they
look around
with their machetes covered in blood and
wake up
of their neighbors and say oh
wait wait a second yep okay we're gonna
stop
so i'm not saying these are easy
predicaments
but certainly you know the idea of
are there situations where it's better
to do something than nothing
i'll tell you what rolling into baghdad
and going into saddam hussein's torture
chambers which we did
and you see the the the uh
the the hook there was hooks like hooks
hanging from ceilings and and and
drainage
where blood would drain in these torture
chambers
you see that a couple times and you
think
i'm okay with us being in here and
getting rid of this guy
i'm going to switch topics i want to
talk to you about your books
and i i'd like to know look you said
right at the beginning of this interview
that
you wanted to be the best navy seal good
navy seal that's what you said you
didn't say the best you want to be good
the best was aiming a little bit too
high yeah yeah i know that's why i
wanted to get the words right
um what are you doing now
what i mean i
i presume that that your life is still
being lived in an
expansion of that the pursuit of that
initial ideal
you've transformed multiple times you're
a civilian you
you're you're a communicator mass
communicator in a variety of different
in a variety of different ways i think
you mentioned we were talking offline a
little bit for example that you have a
clothing line
and i'm going to ask you about that
because that's that's that's a curious
thing to me
um and that is i'm definitely curious
about that
but like what's your mission
and is that the right question is is
that an appropriate question
so there's a
there's there's a there's a quality
let's call it so
as as i as i went through that that
as i created in my mind that ideal
of of what a good seal is what is a good
seal
and and i'm sure you could i could say
okay what do you think jordan oh he's
probably
strong and he's probably fast and he's
probably smart and he's probably
tactically sound and he can probably
shoot a weapon straight
and all those things absolutely all
those things are there
and as you would kind of burn away
the the or if you were to set up a
hierarchy of importance
of what makes a good seal yep
you might think that some people would
think oh well it's probably being the
best shot or it's probably
being the strongest or it's probably
being really good in the water
all those things all those skills that
you think it might be and you could talk
to different seals
and they would all kind of you know some
guy would say it's running some guys say
it's strong some guy would say it's the
best shot
whatever best tactician
but if you offered them one thing
99.9 percent of steels would agree
on what makes you a good seal
and that is you look out for your
teammates
you put your team above yourself
yeah so that's a real inversion of the
things that you just described dave
because
all of those things are dimensions along
which you could be
excellent in a manner that distinguishes
you from the group and elevates you
above them
but you derive from that a claim that
that should all be subordinate to
a reciprocity and
any seal that's a good seal
would tell you that that would be at the
top of the hierarchy you can be the
best shot you can be the best shot you
can be the best diver you can be the
strongest you can be the fastest you can
be the best tactician
if you don't take care of your teammates
none of that none of those other things
matter you you're not even wanted in the
sale teams
that's that's that's what it is so
well do you think that that seems to me
to be true for
functional organizations in general is
that and
and certainly the people i've seen this
is part of the reason why casual
critiques of hierarchies annoy me so
much
because the people i've seen who are
radically successful
don't get there from power they get
there
from mobility but also reciprocity
and yeah um
100 right so when you say to take care
to look out for and to take care of i
think you said to look out for
what flesh that out what does that mean
in the situations that you've been in
and how did that guide your behavior
it's a it's a it's it's a literal
constant daily hourly
by the minute attitude which is okay
hey my my buddy needs me to to to move
over there and cover for that area
that's what i'm gonna do
my buddy needs to me to bring him some
more ammunition
my buddy needs me to help him clean this
weapon my buddy needs to you carry the
boat i need to pick up the boat because
we're moving across the beach
all these things so what are you doing
you're looking
so what like you said moment to moment
so what are you doing you're looking
for ways to be useful constantly how
can i support my teammates
what can i give to them how can i make
them how can i make their situation
better right now
and and that that guy that has that
attitude
is going to have a great reputation in
this year well then you can think too of
course then
the fact that you're outstanding on any
number of dimensions let's say that
becomes an
asset of the team rather than something
that's a competitive liability
because like if you're going to be
looking out for me and i really believe
that
the fact that you're stronger and
smarter than me is actually really good
because now i've got someone who's
stronger than me and smarter than me
who's looking out for me and so
whatever competitive jealousy there
might have been there could be easily
subsumed under appreciation for those
positive attributes
yes and we are going to work together
because guess what you might be the
strongest but i'm a little bit faster
than you right
right right and you might be a good shot
but i'm better in the water than you are
and we're going to be in the water and
shooting so we're each going to have a
chance to be
number one yes so
the reason i went to that
how long did it take you to figure that
out like you said something interesting
about
assembling the image of an ideal seal in
in your imagination and so was that
something that
were you consciously aware of doing that
while you were doing that or did you see
that you were doing that in retrospect
uh unconscious and saw that i did it in
retrospect and
the team the the support your teammate
is something that you
hear immediately and if you listen to it
it's you
you can't miss it now guys miss it guys
definitely miss it
but if your eyes are open and your ears
are open you can't miss it
it's day one seal basic indoctrination
you take care of your swim buddy they
literally say that day one they'll say
take care of your swim buddy
and what does that mean in this in the
swim buddy context what
how would that what does that translate
to practically that means
before jordan gets inspected by the
instructor
i take a look at jordan's gear and make
sure it's all squared away and
say you're good to go as opposed to
seeing that your life jacket's
got a twisted strap and just sitting
there looking straight ahead
no i want to make sure you're okay
that's actually before i check myself
i'm checking you
before i check myself i'm checking you
i'm making sure that you're good to go
see this is partly why these claims the
broad claims that are being made in the
social world
at large now about hierarchical power
um being the the fundamental attribute
of society
is so disturbing to me because this
that this this is not true it's
literally not true
only when a hierarchy becomes radically
dysfunctional does individual power
come to dominate the rest of the time
it's something like what you're saying
is that
and then that's that's that's and and
that's true
let's you know capitalism has a bad rap
let's say morally because of its
selfishness but
the functional organizations that i've
seen that are business organizations
if if the people in there aren't um
motivated by the ethos that you're
describing
no no one bloody well wants to work with
them no one wants to buy
their material no one wants to partner
with them across time
they don't even want to go golfing with
them so
it's just not it's it's so not true it's
completely not true and that's i mean
that's the essence of the books that
i've written about leadership is that
story over and over again
i had a i had a seal platoon commander
that operated via
power his his authority and his power
that's how he operated
we did what he told us because he told
us to do it because he was the highest
ranking guy and you better be quiet and
listen to me and it's going to be my
plan
and you all better just shut up and get
on board with it and we had a
we had a mutiny we had a mutiny in that
seal platoon
where we we went to his boss and said
we're not working with this guy
and he actually ended up getting fired
so everything you just said right while
you well that's exactly right look
there's
there's no stable organization
no organization can run stably across
time
if it's predicate of operation is raw
power
and the reason for that at some point is
that the people who are being
tyrannized are going to band together
and say
no we're not going to do this we're
going to take you out
and so if you don't want to be taken out
you can't exercise tyrannical power
it's it's the intrinsic weakness of
tyranny
and to to confuse functional and
competent organizations with tyranny
is also to make a mockery of the fact
that this
cooperative ethos is actually the
dominating principle if the
if the if the organization is
functioning properly
yeah and as i pointed out i actually
lived through that and i lived through
the other end of the spectrum too when
that platoon commander got fired
the platoon that commander that took his
place was
very humble listened had an open mind
gave us ownership told us to come up
with a plan and we
love that guy and that's the guy that i
try to emulate to this day
and we would have followed that guy
anywhere and it it's it's precise right
and so that's not
power that's not power it's precisely
because he didn't
use his tyrannical power to to drive us
to do what he
what he wanted us to do look whenever
i've been in a situation
and wanted to get the best out of the
people that are working under me or with
me for that matter
um i seed as much responsibility
and authority to them as possible partly
because one of my
predicates of operation is that if i'm
going to
engage in an enterprise with you and i
have to tell you what to do
and or if i told you what to do you
would do a better job
i should find a different person all
that is is indication that i chose the
wrong person
if you're the right person i'm going to
grant you as much autonomy as possible
partly because then you get to have your
own domain
partly then because you're
self-sufficient partly because you do
better
but even more so because then you're
fully committed to the task
and i i don't believe that anybody
occupies a position of leadership for
long
who doesn't know those things and
they're certainly not effective if they
don't know them
no they're not and i i talk to leaders
all day every day
in every every
possible industry that you can think of
and it's
you know one of the things that i end up
saying a lot to leaders
is you know when if you're working for
me jordan and you come to me with a plan
of how you want to execute a project or
an operation or a task
my goal my goal is that we're going to
use your idea
that's my goal my goal is that whatever
you present to me
if it's if it's going to get the job
done we're good we're going with it
you know then at least the person can
learn from what they're doing and be
better the next time right if it's
minimally viable why not let them run it
yeah
sometimes it's an emergency and you
can't do that but
yeah yeah and by the way if there's
urgency and i can't do that
okay by this time you and i have built
an up enough trust
that you know that if i say hey we need
to go over there right now you go yep
got it
right right and so so we do get into
situations like that happens right and
that's
that's something you don't want to do
too often because just as we discussed
earlier you burn up your leadership
credibility by doing that so you can use
power if you're a leader but
but judiciously and seldom and you need
a good rationale
and people have to trust you and so
that's the other issue is that
we could we could think about the
preconditions for trust because
if the organization isn't running on
trust then everybody's
at each other's throat constantly and
all there is is backbiting and confusion
and so to trust means i i have to i have
to
i have to what would i say i have to
have faith in your motives
and i have to see that you're doing your
best to align your motives with mind
and i have to believe that that's
genuine because otherwise the enterprise
isn't going to succeed
given all the other things it's going to
have to face
yeah it's a it's another you know you
bring up the term alignment
and when i work with companies sometimes
sometimes we'll start talking about
alignment and and
quite frankly in most cases
in vast majority of cases if you and i
are at a company
if we go high enough high enough
up what i call the the ladder of
alignment if we go
high enough up that ladder we'll get to
a point where we're
gonna be aligned because look right
definitely
we're trying to um take care of our team
we're trying to provide a good service
to our clients and we're trying to be
profitable
and if look if that's what we're trying
to do and 99.9
of the times the companies that i work
with i have to talk them through this
but i can say
we can get to a point where we are
aligned now what
alignment has like a like a like a like
a cousin
or or maybe a step cousin called agenda
where where you've got your agenda over
here and i've got my agenda over here
and you're trying to get more funds for
your department and i'm trying to get
more funds for my department
and so we can kind of sometimes it can
feel like our agendas
we're not aligned yeah now oftentimes i
say look if
if jordan's agenda is to get more
funding for his department so he can
invest more and make more money for the
team
his agenda is aligned and that's great
that i have no problem with your agenda
it's when you know you're try trying to
create your own fight them because
you're going to leave the company and
you're going to go do something else and
i start to sense that
and and whenever yeah and all that's
going on underground and no one's really
talking about it
right right when i get a company
where they can't come to a they can't
come to an agreement about something
they can't they cannot so we walk them
up the the alignment ladder and all of a
sudden you realize oh wait a second
this person's just trying to make money
and this right
really wants to take care of the team
now i'll tell you i'll take them further
up the alignment ladder and say listen
if you really want to make money and you
want to take care of the team
guess what if you have a good team that
you take care of you're going to make
more money
yeah yeah yeah but you can get aligned
unless people are starting to take care
of themselves
instead of take care of the team which
goes back to what we were just talking
about which is also extremely
short-sighted in my
estimation because for a bunch of
reasons i i lined some of this out in in
this new book
this i realized a long time ago that
there isn't much difference there might
be no difference actually technically
speaking
in in taking care of yourself and in
taking care of other people
and here's the reason so you might say
well
i'm one person and everyone else is a
group of people and so there's that
competition between me as one person and
what this one person wants
and the group but that's not true
because i'm
actually a group and the reason i'm a
group is
well there's me today but there's me
over the next week and there's me over
the next month and then there's me over
the next year and over the next five
years and over the next 10 years and
the me that exists right now can't
betray the me that's going to exist next
week by doing something short-sighted
and impulsive that will you know produce
a burst of impulsive pleasure but will
compromise
the future and so if i'm taking myself
into account
seriously which i'm an entity that
has multiple incarnations let's say
across very large spans of time
then i immediately have a community that
i have to serve i have to serve the 80
year old person that i'm going to become
and the difference between that and
serving 80 year old people
in the community is negligible it's the
same thing
so if i'm taking care of someone in a in
a senior's home for example
there the difference between that and
how i'm going to be taken care of when
i'm 80 is negligible
and so there there's no there's
there's there's no way out of the
ethical demand of
of serving the group even if you're even
if your selfishness
is is is of the most enlightened kind
well that's one of the most beautiful
things about this about this
the whole thing conceptually is that
if i put the team before myself if i put
the mission and the team before myself
and by being a good team player i
i lift up jordan and i and i make you
look good and i give you the support you
need
the beautiful thing about this is
eventually
i'm going to win right i'm 100
going to win and people get
short-sighted as you're talking about
where i think you know what if i can if
i can pull this project away
from jordan i can raise my head up and
get some credit
for this the boss is going to look at me
and he's probably going to give me a
promotion and that that might work
once that might work once yeah or twice
and then my reputation is oh you don't
want jocko on your team because he's the
one that's going to be moving around
trying to make himself look good
instead of trying to accomplish the
mission yeah so ultimately
if if you take care of people if you're
a good seal if you're a good team player
you will win in the end that's what's
going to happen and yes and you'll win
you'll win surrounded by people who are
thrilled to death that you won
and so and that's that's that's a much
better form of winning than to be
bitter and alone yes snatched standing
on the mouth
right right absolutely and and the fact
that it's on you know you can only get
away with that once or twice is dead
relevant because human beings are very
sensitive to negative emotion we
remember
and one of the things we really remember
is betrayal
and so if if you don't play the game
straight and you have to play the game
over and over with the same people
then you're dead in the water and then
you're going to be in your own little
hell
you're going to think well why does it
why won't anybody play with me
and the answer that is well you don't
play fair and people gave you a chance a
few times and you demonstrated that and
like there's no coming back so
yeah and the reason i went off on this
tangent yeah
because you asked me your mission now
what am i doing now
you bet you better and i think that
along the way in my career in the in the
navy
i was so ingrained with the fact of
trying to be a good
teammate yeah that when i retired
i kept just trying to
help people out and say hey you know
what i i
i can teach you something about
leadership do you want to know something
about leadership i i can
i can maybe i can help you with this or
i can at least talk you through
and maybe i can share some stories of
what i've learned about human nature and
and that way you don't have to learn
those lessons by beating your head up
against the wall
and and then maybe i can help you out
with
hey putting some stuff together that you
can take as supplements and that's going
to make you a little bit healthier and
stronger and
and by the way we're we're trying to
rebuild our community
in new england where we came from where
we used to have a bunch of factories
making clothes and
maybe we could rebuild that and that way
everything ah so great
so there's this question and so so tell
me tell me about that so
because it's kind of a surprise right to
you have a clothing line i think well
that's so that's so funny
and i that that jocko has a clothing
line it's it's so cool that that's the
case and not not
expected so i knew there was a back
story there
so um i don't imagine that it stems from
an obsession with fashion
you called it dude okay so so what
happened and why did you get interested
in it and what's going on
okay so um i was you know i
started my podcast and i was interacting
with people and i i talk about jiu jitsu
a lot brazilian jiu jitsu
i'm a a very big supporter of people
training jiu jitsu
and mixed martial arts in general but i
am absolutely a jiu jitsu guy
so a lot of people started doing jiu
jitsu and they started training and and
so they would ask me that the
the uniform for jiu-jitsu is called a
gee
and people would ask me hey i'm starting
jiu-jitsu or i started jiu-jitsu and i
need to get a ghee
what kind should i get and
i knew from having ghees over the years
that gees were made in
china and whatever horrible
slave labor scenarios are happening
there
and and i knew that there was also one
company
up in maine and i'm i'm from new england
as well one company up in maine that was
actually making these jiu-jitsu gis
in america and and i had seen them
online and
and the story was kind of presented
online that this guy named pete
he was a new england kid and saw the
factories get shut down and we all you
know we all did that we all saw
when i was growing up the factories
there was no there was no one in them
yep
and and he saw that and he was also a
jiu-jitsu guy and so
he wanted to make these jiu-jitsu
in america as he started to go down that
path he realized that the material that
you would get to sew together a ghee was
not produced anywhere in america so he
decided he was going to get a loom
to weave this material and
he starts asking around and poking
around and eventually finds that in a
500 000 square foot abandoned factory in
lewiston maine there is one loom that
hadn't been shipped overseas
and the woman that kind of owned it
was planning to one day put that loom in
a museum
and he said i'll buy it from you and so
he bought this massive loom
you know it's as big as a couple beds
put together
weighs thousands and thousands of pounds
and he gets some of his buddies and they
go and drag this loom out of this
factory and they take it apart
what a cool finding what a remarkable
piece of equipment
completely remarkable and he finds a guy
he finds people that
knew about these things find some
old-timers there was a guy named lenny
who since died but he used to work on
looms
and he hired him and said why we he says
what do you want to do he said we got to
make this thing work
so he starts making he starts weaving
this material gets this thing up and
running
so one day and i'm following the story
i've been following
i've been following that story for three
or four years and
i'd actually reached out to him and said
hey man
i know you're up in maine i'm from up
there um
what do you think you know can i get
some of your geese i'd like to like to
have some of your gis and
how much are they or whatever and i
wouldn't even hear back from him
because he's in maine these guys you
know i make fun of him because he's up
in maine he's in farmington maine
population seven thousand
so anyways one day i'm doing like a
a live social media interaction with
people and someone says
hey i'm just starting jiu jitsu what
kind of geese should i get
and i said i'll tell you what you should
get an origin gee and by the way i said
if anybody on here knows this guy named
pete roberts
that runs that company up there if you
could please tell him i want to talk to
him that'd be really cool
so a few days go by and i get like a
message that says hey i
reached out through my business
connections and i found this guy pete
roberts
here's his number or whatever here's his
email so i say all right
great so we set up a a skype call
this was a few years ago and we meet
each other
and we talk for four hours and
i come walking out of my office and my
wife says it sounds like you were
talking to yourself in there
because we were just you know we were on
the same page
so i ended up flying up to maine we we
we had a stake and we had a handshake
and we
merged and and started working together
and what was great was he had he had
this
great people up there and was building
these keys but he didn't have a platform
he's in farmington maine there's not a
bunch of jiu jitsu studios in farmington
maine
well i had luckily a platform to talk to
people right well and
no matter how good your product man and
everyone needs to know this
the world will not beat a pathway to
your doorway for your damn product you
need to pay attention
to sales and marketing and you can't be
contemptuous of it
it's like who the hell is going to buy
something they don't know about
so we shook hands we started working
together
and once so then we started making
jujitsuki's and believe it or not you
know now we had a bunch of people that
wanted these jiu-jitsu
because they're the best in the world
they're made in america they're made by
americans
with with their american cotton and
woven on american looms so it's just
it's a beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing and and one day i
was in the airport
and i'm sitting there in the airport as
we're selling a bunch of jiu jitsu
and i'm i'm looking around and i called
up
pete and i said hey pete i said how many
people do you actually know that do jiu
jitsu
and he said he's like i don't know like
maybe 50 or 100.
and i said how many people do you know
that wear jeans
and he said everybody and i said why
aren't we making jeans
and he said let me let me go so
the next thing we did was we started
making jeans because because
because the iconic american genes
that you wear aren't made in america the
iconic american genes that people think
represent america they're not made in
america
and and that's wrong and and the other
crazy thing about this is
you know so do you make good genes we
make the best jeans in the do they have
spandex in them
they do they do they have their they
have a little bit of stretch in them
we've got a heavy pair and a lighter
pair
and yeah they're it's where can people
find these
or how do they look for them origin
usa.org
if you go to jaco.com you can find all
this stuff
and and um so we started everybody needs
good genes then we started making boots
yeah and we're making everything we're
making you know we
we started making a bunch of supplements
and that started from
i drink tea another shocking thing you
might want
it is shocking i'm married to a brit and
at some point i started drinking tea and
so i started making tea
and then i i started making other
supplements
and and again it was like make high
quality stuff
that works and people need it they want
it
and we're doing that thing of being a
teammate
of helping people out so
that i knew there was a good story in
that clothing
it's a great story it's a great great
story absolutely
if you've ever seen a i don't know maybe
you could help me with my
with my personality what i like about
that too i've learned something in the
last while like i
i noticed very much that people
allow a casual and unconscious contempt
to stop them from
well to elevate the status of what
they're doing
i would say but also to to
allow them the luxury of not having to
consider the importance of all the
things they're not doing
now and that stops them from taking
opportunities
so you know well it's
i was watching this show last night it
was the devil wears prada it was about
fashion industry and this girl who
started you instantly thought of me
absolutely i thought that's right the
jocko fashion special
but this girl um she has contempt for
the fashion industry you know and that's
portrayed as a moral virtue and i wasn't
on her side to begin with i thought no
you know
there's probably something to this and
what you should do is shut up and learn
about it before you criticize it
but it's more comfortable in some sense
to have contempt for things
you know and it's so interesting to talk
to you about your clothing line
you know you saw opportunity there in
all sorts of ways
and it fitted into this context of let's
say of being a broader service
and because you didn't have contempt for
it at all at any level for the machinery
for the manufacturing
for the fact of making clothing for
having your name associated with that
for all of that
and then it enables you to see an
opportunity there and to do something
immediately
and then to make an enterprise grow and
work
and so that's another thing is that that
that casual contempt
for what you can't do that's a that's a
real ethical mistake
yeah that one will definitely i see
among academics you know there's always
contempt for businessmen
and and and and the immorality of the
capitalist enterprise and then i see
among businessmen
you know contempt for intellectualism in
the ivory tower
and i think it's not doing either of you
guys much good you know because
you both have something to bring to the
table in a real sense
and some appreciate appreciative
appreciation for what the other one
knows that you don't
is well worth everyone's attempt and
then everybody gets to win
too it's like well great man you've got
this business enterprise more power to
you and
and then you can say too well you know
great you teach all these people and you
have this advanced learning and
isn't the world better because we can
both bring that to the table
no need for for that envy not at all
just it just contaminates things yeah
unless you let your ego slide in there
and
and you start to think well i've been i
studied so hard and yet i'm only making
whatever i'm making as a yeah well
that's
that's a huge but look it's a huge part
of the culture war i believe
is that there's a there's a tremendous
resentment in the university
about the fact that uh high-level
intellectual endeavor
doesn't attract disproportionate salary
when other occupations do but it
certainly has
no shortage of other rewards you know
absolute job security being one of them
and freedom for that matter so anyways
anyways um actually i've been surprised
that
in all you know there's all this talk in
america right now about
the divisiveness in america and yeah
i've been surprised that
the the the ego hasn't come up more
often
because you mean as a topic as a as a
as a causal effect yeah yeah okay sure
you know of
the fact that while i go to have a
conversation with someone
and i just think that i'm right i think
that my viewpoints are right and your
viewpoints are wrong
and worse worse not just wrong
contemptible exactly that's like the
ultimate expression of wrong
right they're beneath my consideration
right yeah and that's that's not good
that's definitely not good
how do i how do i listen to anything
that you say how do i
how do i find any common ground with you
if i think that what you think is
contemptible
and so therefore we can have a
conversation if we don't have a
conversation
we can't find any mutual ground and that
means we can't find solutions to the
problems that we're facing
and yes and it means when push comes to
shove we have to fight
yes it does i'm here to tell you
that's not a good option
you know that's a good place to stop
fair enough that was great man
thank you appreciate it i loved it well
thank you appreciate it
yeah so it's good to see you
it's good to see you too and it's so
it's so nice to see that
that all of what you're talking about is
finding its audience
i like the kids books too we never
talked about them
oh yeah the kids books i i i feel like
um there is no more there's no better
gratification
for me than the handwritten letters
the the the emails that i get but mostly
the handwritten letters from kids that
are
six seven eight nine years old just did
my first pull-up
got an a on my math test guys oh isn't
that cool
it's crazy yes how could you have
anything better than that
to know that you were part of that so so
tell me about that maybe we'll stop with
that tell me about that
like tell tell me about the kids books
how many you've self-published them
how many have sold well so i didn't i
didn't self publish all of them
okay i the first two went through a
normal publisher
and what happened was so so the first
one is called way the warrior kid
and and right basically i have four kids
myself
three daughters one son as i was raising
my kids
i couldn't really find books that
articulated the values that i might want
my children to be reading about
and so i wrote my own books so
the first one way the warrior kid it's a
kid he's bullied
he doesn't know his times tables so he
thinks he's stupid he doesn't know how
to swim so he can't do any of the fun
stuff that the other kids are doing
and he's getting bullied this is common
things that kids face and he kind of
breaks down last day of school
everything kind of hits him at once and
he goes home
and um he remembers that his uncle is
coming to stay with him for the summer
and his uncle his uncle is in the seal
teams
and he presents all these problems that
he's having to his uncle and his uncle
says listen
we can solve these problems but you got
to commit it's going to take discipline
it's going to take hard work
teaches the kid how to study teaches the
kid how to make flash cards teaches the
kid how to eat right teaches the kid how
to work out
brings the kid to jiu jitsu classes so
he learns how to defend himself
kid goes back to school and he's he's in
a much better place
and and so then that series carries on
with different types of
situations that kids get into and so i
wrote the first one way the warrior kid
the second one mark's mission
and then i had written a kid's book um a
kid's book called mikey and the dragons
and and i had written it i finished it
in august
and i talked to my publisher and i said
hey you know i wrote this kid's book i'm
sorry you know
it sorry i didn't let you know earlier
but i really want the book to come out
for christmas
and my publisher said yeah well you know
that's not really going to happen and i
said yeah but i really want it to come
out
by christmas and by this time i think
i'd written
like three new york times best-selling
books for whatever that's worth so
it wasn't like i was you know scrapping
around
trying to throw this together i had a
pretty good vision of what to do here
and i said here's a lot yeah so i said
please can i you know get this thing
published by christmas
and they and they said they said there's
no scenario where this book gets
published by christmas and i said
i said are you sure and then yeah yeah
and i said watch this
and so i started publishing about a week
yep i started my own publishing company
we finished the
uh the art inside the book and the book
came out
before thanksgiving and that was the
beginning of of
jocko publishing and so yes
i've published it and then i just wrote
the uh the latest way the warrior kid
book
way the warrior kid four field manual
and and again the most
rewarding thing that happens to me on a
daily basis is i get to open up letters
from kids that are
seven eight nine 10 11 years old that
just you know did their first pull-up or
ran a mile in a certain amount of time
or they
so cool they like it's so cool to see
that because i mean
it's it's an unbelievably deep instinct
that makes that satisfying
like i have the same experience i don't
ever see
anything as satisfying as getting a
message from someone who says
um i've followed what you've been
talking about and here's what i've done
that's improved my life because of it
it's this is there's a you know when you
read online comments
the negative ones are salient
right they've got potency but and people
are wired to
feel more negative emotion than positive
emotion it affects us more
more uh we feel a loss more strongly
than we feel an equivalent gain um
the one exception to that might be those
kinds of letters
they're so salient and it's really
curious i mean that must be the deep
that must be something like the deep
instinct of fatherhood
that that pleasure that's intrinsic in
watching
someone who's younger younger generally
speaking not always but generally
speaking thrive
it's so satisfying and yeah i think that
goes back to the
to the concept of being a good teammate
yes definitely it's the deepest part of
it
and you're helping someone get on the
correct path when they're eight years
old and you you know
when i people say oh me all the time the
parents write me too
the parents say hey you know thank you
i got more out of this book than my kids
did right they they say right
as well the the the the way that these
books come together
it's like you're being a good teammate
because you're putting someone on the
right path at a young age i always
people say i wish i would have had this
book when i was right right well
yes absolutely me too that's a father
between pages that
it is exactly that because the
fundamental role of a father as far as i
can tell
is encouragement and i mean that
technically is that
you your job is to instill courage in or
to
or to or to encourage courage i suppose
in in in your children to make them
resilient in that matter to make them
confident in their ability to face the
world but also able to face the world
and that warrior kid book it's such a
different approach to the problem of
bullying
it reminded me when you were talking
about it about the simpsons there's
nelson manse is the bully in the
simpsons
and he's quite a complex character
actually and if he bullies you
there's a pretty high probability that
the reason he's doing it is because
you're doing something
stupid and contemptible so he's got this
kind of corrective function
and he's not a bad kid even though he's
a bully
some of his bully compatriots are bad
kids but he's not he's from a
family that's not doing well he has his
reasons for for what he's like
but he is kind of a corrective you know
um and
there's a scene too in the simpsons
where one of the teachers says to ralph
poor ralph
that the children are right to laugh at
you ralph
which is a hilarious line but also
absolutely terrible
but you know in your warrior kid book
the message there is
one way of dealing with your
inadequacies is to
rid yourself of them and it isn't
self-evident that people who point out
your inadequacies are your enemy
now that doesn't mean that bullies can't
exploit and it doesn't mean that
bullying isn't reprehensible but by by
the same token
you know critics a critic who points out
a weakness
has actually offered you a pathway to
development
a true pathway to development
so and your your attitude to the kid was
look
kid no one's gonna laugh at you if
you're the best swimmer or maybe you
don't even have to be the best but
but you could swim you could be stronger
you know you could
you could elevate yourself yeah it's um
it's it's it's so fun to write these
books because
i mean i got first of all i got to
experience it and you know i always tell
people
people say oh did you get bullied
because i'm i'm a bigger guy now i was
like oh when you're 10 you get bullied
by 11
year olds that's right all right exactly
there's always going to be somebody
that's bigger than you
um in the second book the bully is like
a psychological bully his name is nathan
james and nathan he's not physically
threatening you but he's
he's making fun of you and he's picking
on you and he'll take it to the point
where
he might you know feel some
repercussions but then he'd be quiet
and so you know this kid mark says to
his uncle hey i'm gonna
fight this kid i'm gonna fight him
and the uncle says well
okay if it comes to that but before you
fight him
so that's when you published yourself i
presume
uh no no no this was this was still this
was still um this is book two
oh really okay well my mistake i said
surprising well that was a while ago do
you think you could get a book like that
published now
i'm not 100 sure i've got another i've
got i wrote a novel that's coming out
which we should probably touch on
uh which which went through like
multiple screenings to make sure that it
wasn't
offensive and whatever else uh nathan
james the bully
he picks on the kids but he talks and
and his uncle you know
the kid mark says hey i want to fight
this kid and his uncle says okay if it
comes to that
but before you fight him i want you to
gather some intel he says what do you
mean gather some intel i want you to
collect some intelligence i want to know
why he acts this way and so
he watches he uh mark watches this kid
nathan james for a couple days and he
says
goes back and reports to his uncle this
kid he
he doesn't eat healthy he eats potato
chips
half a bag of potato chips he's dirty he
doesn't change his clothes
his socks don't match he's got holes in
his jeans he's a slob
totally lacks discipline i think i
should fight him
and then he says well why do you think
he's like that
you need to do further intel and i'm
sure you can see where this is going
eventually follows him and realize the
kid is kind of on his own
and the reason he has a bag of potato
chips a half a bag of potato chips
because
his mom's not home at night and there's
no dad to be found
and and we don't even know what's going
on but he lives in some
in some apartment building above a auto
repair shop and
and maybe his jeans wears the same jeans
every day because that's the only pair
he's got
and so instead of fighting this kid
maybe you should try and help him
mm-hmm and that's where that goes
so yeah there's uh there's another novel
that i wrote which is coming out in the
fall
is um it it's
it's it's definitely going to be
interesting what the critics
say about it i'm looking forward to it
i'm looking forward to their
um their assessment it's about a it's
about a
two brothers one brother is kind of a
handsome kind of street smart kid smart
good looking the other brother is uh
got some kind of a unidentified
disorder mental disorder mental handicap
and basically is an autistic guy and
he's obsessed with washing machines
and he works at a laundromat
and um well
the the laundromat is eventually going
to be up for sale and the brother
the younger brother who's a little bit
more street smart besides
if that happens my my older brother is
never going to be happy again because
he's not going to have this laundromat
and he decides he's going to do
something to get money
to buy that laundry mat and the only way
he can figure out to do that is by doing
something that's not legal so he goes
for it
and well that's the story but and that's
coming out when
it comes out in the fall it's called
final spin
how long have you been working on that
uh well i write about uh probably
i wrote an original draft of it probably
15 years ago
and then just kind of set it aside and
this is then i
i dusted it off because it never left my
mind
this story never left my mind because
ultimately it's about a
you know it's about can you be happy and
what kind of sacrifices are you willing
to make to be happy and
what about people that are stuck in a
rut you know when i was growing up there
was all these kids that were smarter
than me and
funnier than me and better athletes than
me and and
i would look around and they would get
stuck in a rut right
right and not really do anything and it
would
be a little bit sad yes very and
you know i was lucky enough like you
said i i joined the navy and all of a
sudden had a goal and had an aim and
wanted to be a good seal and that was
enough to
kind of put me in the right direction
yeah so what
what's next what do you want where do
you want to take this
what's your ambition teaching people
you're communicating with them on a very
broad level
that's where do where do you see this
going if it went where you want it to go
the the ambition the goal is to help
more people is to help more people
help more kids become more confident
help more leaders
do a better job of leading their teams
help
people be on a better path in their life
healthier
and and doing productive things in the
world that's
i think the best thing i can do right
now at this point yeah well that just
seems like generally speaking that just
seems like the best
i think well once
it isn't clear why you would be
motivated to do anything else
it's like that actually is the best
thing you talked about these letters
it's like
what could you do that would be better
than that i mean if you were as greedy
as you could possibly be
you can't get better than that so it's
so rewarding
so yeah and and again the biggest reward
is is
when you when you get a letter from
somebody that decided they weren't going
to kill themselves yeah yeah right
because they heard you talking on the
podcast or they read they read the book
discipline equals freedom and they said
wait a second i'm trapped why am i
trapped trapped because i'm blaming
other people
i'm trapped because i'm not sticking
to the things that i know i should do
right
and they get on the right path and you
know they always say you changed my life
and i always said and change your life
you did
which is the truth
thanks a lot thanks for having me man
good seeing you
good to see you too